bonsoir est-ce que votre émission
culturelle tout de suite le sommaire La
Ferme de belémba consacre samedi une
journée à l'art des marionnettes les
explications avec Yann lavabobre le
directeur de la salle guyancourtoise la
dixième concours de guitare ce samedi et
dimanche à Montigny-le-Bretonneux pour
en parler en plateau Vincent Leblet
membre du conseil d'administration de
l'école de digue du Manet et puis le
Festival de Cannes c'est en ce moment et
sur place l'occasion de rencontrer les
Yvelines noires qui sont présents sur la
Croisette parmi eux le réalisateur
Nicolas campsofa mais avant tout ça je
vous propose d'ouvrir une page musique
samedi et dimanche et le dixième
concours de guitare de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui se déroule
salle Jacques Brel pour en parler en
plateau Vincent le glaive bonsoir vous
êtes membre du conseil d'administration
de l'école de musique du Manet vous êtes
aussi élève en classe de flux de
traversière tout à fait pour le la
petite anecdote en disant ce concours a
permis de rassembler quelques 400
guitaristes de France entière et de
l'étranger justement d'abord pour ce
concours comment les guitaristes sont
sélectionnés pour ce concours de
guitares alors il s'inscrivent
l'inscription est libre et tous les
guitaristes qui le souhaitent peuvent
s'inscrire c'est un concours de guitare
classique donc on a un réseau notamment
par la presse qui fait la promotion de
de ce concours et donc cette année nous
avons 35 inscrits qui viennent de la
France entière et notamment un candidat
également qui vient de la Belgique
est-ce qu'ils ont des niveaux assez
différents où est-ce qu'il faut avoir
quand même un bon niveau pour participer
à ce concours alors c'est là une la
particularité du concours de guitare de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est qu'en fait
il est ouvert à tous les guitaristes ça
va des plus jeunes qui ont un ou deux
ans de guitare et ça leur permet de se
frotter pour une première à ce type
d'exercice jusqu'à des professionnels en
devenir pour qui le concours fait office
un peu d'antichambre au monde
professionnel de concertiste et j'en
veux pour preuve que le lauréat du
premier prix
se voit ouvrir
les portes du Festival International de
guitare de Paris pour un récital cette
année qui se déroulera en novembre
prochain alors les au
ditions les
jeunes participent au concours ce sera
samedi entre 10h30 et 14h et 17h ils
sont auditionnés comment ils ont un
thème précis ils ont je présume un
timing à respecter alors il y a
effectivement des morceaux qui sont
choisis par niveau par le directeur
artistique du concours Nicolas Sassot
qui est
concertiste et professeur de guitare le
dimanche à 18h30 qui sera pour
l'occasion de ses 10 ans en concert à
18h30 en l'église Saint-Martin de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux concert ouvert à
tous donc j'habite tous les testateurs à
venir assister à ce récital et donc
Nicolas Sasso fait une sélection de
morceaux pour les différents niveaux et
chaque chaque
participant présente le morceau de son
niveau il y a une délibération qui
permet d'établir des prix pour chaque
niveau
le jury qui composent ce jury alors le
jury le jury est composé de Nicolas
Sasso de Didier jalquin directeur de
l'école de musique de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux de l'école de
musique du Manet pardon et qui est à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux dans le quartier
du Mans et Tanya chaniot concertise
international et Emmanuel de rera qui
également un concertiste de guitare
classique donc ça c'est samedi si on
veut venir écouter les élèves les
guitaristes en devenir et ceux qui sont
un peu plus professionnels ce sera donc
entre 10h30 14h 17h à la salle Jacques
Brel et puis dimanche il y aura un
concert à 15h le concert de la horaire
voilà le concert de Nicolas Sasso à
18h30 tout à fait donc ça me dit soir
18h30 église Saint-Martin concert de
Nicolas Sasso et 15h dimanche salle
Jacques Brel le concert des lauréats
ouvert également à tous un mot quand
même qui sont l’école de musique du
Manet donc à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
combien d'élèves reçues et quel type de
discipline vous faites évidemment les
disciplines traditionnelles ça je
présume il y a peut-être d'autres aussi
alors 350L 350L en 2000 pour cette cette
saison une école qui existe depuis 1998
qui est ouverte à toutes les toutes les
musiques les instruments les plus
classiques le piano le violon la guitare
la flûte traversière mais également des
instruments un peu plus exotiques comme
les styles drums une école de musique
qui est très dynamique un grand nombre
d'ensemble ensemble de style drums
ensemble de guitare un petit orchestre
un orchestre de jazz une école de
musique qui participe à la vie également
de la commune au travers du Téléthon au
travers des fêtes de quartier au travers
des fêtes de la ville vraiment une école
qui est très investie très dynamique
cette école à la fois des tout-petits et
à la fois elle prépare aussi aux
ateliers pour le bac de préparation tout
à fait donc il y a des ateliers pour les
plus jeunes pour qu'ils découvrent tous
les instruments de musique et fasse le
choix de l'instrument qui le veulent
pratiquer et également pour les élèves
de baccalauréat il y a une section qui
leur permet de préparer l'option musique
du baccalauréat merci beaucoup Vincent
Logan
assister à ce dixième concours de
guitare la saga de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce sera samedi
toute la journée et puis dimanche le
concours de lauréats le concert pardon
DeLorean c'est un 15h merci beaucoup
dans quelques instants nous allons
parler marionnette avec Nicolas Gervais
mais avant je voudrais vous proposer
deux rendez-vous musicaux qui ont
également lieu ce week-end direction
tout d'abord la batterie pour ce samedi
soir pour un concert de Michel ndjollet
au seydo une ambiance sous les grooves
pour une artiste qui aime à la fois le
hip-hop le reggae le rock et le jazz
elle a été nommée neuf mois neuf fois
pardon grimmy Awards concert à partir de
10 euros 50 je propose d'écouter cet
artiste elle a une voix très envoûtante
je sors tu
allez un tout autre style maintenant
direction cette fois le musée de
Port-Royal Deschamps à Magny-les-Hameaux
pour écouter le quatuores Kuro c'est de
la musique classique un tatouage qui
connaît bien les lieux puisque les
musiciens ont déjà enregistré un CD ce
dimanche au programme des œuvres de
Hayden et de Mozart tarif plein à 20
euros 10 euros pour les étudiants et les
moins de 12 ans
samedi 23 mai la ferme de Bel et pas de
Guyancourt une journée consacrée au
marionnettes Nicolas Gervais vous en
propose le détail avec Yann lavabo
une journée spéciale consacrée à la
marionnette ça s'appelle c'est de la
manipulation c'est le samedi 23 mai à la
ferme de Bel et bain à Guyancourt pour
nous en parler on retrouve le directeur
de la salle Johan lavabo c'est tout de
suite maintenant dans le kiosque et
magnifique
c'est une journée consacrée à la
marionnette du matin jusqu'à jusqu'à la
fin de l'après-midi la marionnette pour
tous les âges et dans tous ses états
donc on commence le matin pour les plus
jeunes spectateurs et puis au fil des
heures le spectateur grandit
timide et bien c'est l'histoire d'un
petit garçon d'un petit garçon qui est
timide comme le titre l'indique et qui
va qui va apprendre à vaincre sa peur
pour réaliser ses rêves un très joli
spectacle de manipulation écrit par
Catherine Verlaguet et interprété par
Bénédicte Guichardon ce n'est pas de la
marionnette classique c'est de la
manipulation d'objets justement c'est
pour ça qu'on dit la marionnette dans
tous ses états la marionnette c'est
extrêmement variée c'est une discipline
qui se renouvelle sans cesse on est loin
du guignol d'antan ou la marionnette à
fil et là donc timide ça s'adresse aux
enfants à partir de 3 ans un spectacle à
découvrir en famille avec les parents
tu peux commencer à parler
ma mère il s'appelait Yulia
j'imagine qu'elle était belle
je me souviens de son parfum
à 14h30 ce sera valise d'enfance un
spectacle de la compagnie pipassole une
compagnie des Yvelines qui raconte avec
beaucoup de pudeurs en fait c'est un
grand-père qui raconte à sa petite fille
la déportation la déportation de sa
famille voilà ce sont les on a on a fêté
la comment dire la célébrée la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale les 70 ans de la
fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et on
a voulu voilà permettre aux jeunes
spectateurs à partir de 7-8 ans de se
plonger dans cette histoire qui fait
partie de notre notre héritage le
spectacle a été désigné spectacle coup
de cœur du festival mondial des théâtres
de marionnettes à Charleville-Mézières
je suis bien aise de vous dire cela car
vous savez bien que moi je n'ai pas un
décilitre pas un centilitre oh mais pas
le moindre petit millilitres
vous n'avez pas lieu de vous plaindre et
l'on sait que vous nagez dans
l'abondance
dans l'abondance ce thème où est-ce que
tu as vu ça que je nage si je suis comme
un coup de prêt ton père s'il vous plaît
de Paris discours et les dépenses que tu
fais faire aucun chaud on viendra ne
couper le tuyau pour me voler et qu'elle
dépense à ce que je fais
parce que tu trouves ça bien d'être si
propre et te sentir si bon comme si tu
étais un de la forme oh
à 18h une adaptation de l'Avare de
Molière une pièce une pièce très
originale ou en fait toute la thématique
liée à l'argent et remplacer par l'eau
et donc en fait il s'agit de de chercher
l'eau donc voilà une adaptation de
Molière assez jubilatoire sur fond de
pénurie des ressources naturelles et
c'est un spectacle que nous proposons
avec le service du développement durable
de la Ville de Guyancourt
voilà et après les marionnettes à la
ferme de belle et bas je vous propose de
poursuivre cette émission avec Catherine
laissez-vous manipuler par Catherine
petite manipulations et toujours à
Guyancourt ce sont les 20 ans de la
mezzanine la salle d'exposition située
au premier étage de l'Hôtel de Ville à
cette occasion la mezzanine présente une
sélection des œuvres les plus
emblématiques une façon de montrer la
diversité de sa collection l'entrée est
libre jusqu'au 26 juin la renaissance de
la fontaine de la tonne au château de
Versailles depuis lundi plus forts
symboles du pouvoir du roi soleil a
repris vie il aura fallu deux ans de
travaux pour une centaine de personnes
rien que cela les explications avec
wilfriedrichi et l'audimon
dorure alors fin marbre de Carrare les
jardins du château de Versailles ont
retrouvé leur visage d'antan celui
imaginé par Le Nôtre trois siècles plus
tôt avec la restauration du bassin de
l'atone c'est l'un des plus anciens et
des plus importants éléments du parc qui
reprend son éclat d'origine nos
visiteurs vont retrouver le bassin de la
tonne parce que ce bassin de latin était
ici mais je crois qu'on ne pouvait pas
se faire une idée de sa splendeur car il
était singulièrement détériorée il était
à l'intérieur bien sûr mais il était
aussi à l'extérieur et retrouver toute
sa beauté retrouver la couleur des
marbres retrouver l'étincelant des
plombs et ben je crois que c'est très
important quand vous faites une
promenade à Versailles que vous arrivez
en haut des terrasses que vous ne savez
pas que ce bassin est là et que tout un
coup vous le découvrez et si en plus il
est en eau je pense que là c'est
formidable initié en 2012 grâce au
mécénat de la Fondation philanthropia
cette rénovation n'était pas uniquement
indispensable sur le plan esthétique la
structure qui supporte le décor
de ce chantier et de nos métiers en
général c'est de voir dans les matériaux
est-ce que les matériaux peuvent être
encore conservés avec toutes les
techniques modernes de consolidation que
l'on que l'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
avec des résines avec des cols avec des
ou alors est-ce que les matériaux sont
trop dégradés et il faut les remplacer
ces chantiers de Louis XIV associés des
matériaux locaux avec des matériaux
étrangers exogènes qui souvent étaient
très très cher et dans la restauration
comme on cherche à reconduire ces mêmes
matériaux on a eu le même problème de
trouver de la meulière aux oser très
difficile de trouver de la pierre
Molière c'est presque plus et c'est plus
difficile que de trouver du marbre de
Carrare pour la meulière c'est en partie
alors on doit dire les choses c'est en
partie des rognons de Molière que on a
pu acheter à des paysans vous savez dans
des champs parfois il y a des revues en
Molières qui a remontent à la surface
mais ça ne suffisait pas tout faire le
reste on l'a trouvé en matériaux
démolition certains venant d'un hangar
de l'aérostation dans le fond du parc
qui avait été construit pour la guerre
de 14 mais qui avait encore des Bleus
beaux blocs de Molière appareillés et
qu'on a récupéré et d'autres qui
venaient carrément je crois de
démolition de pavillons des années
1920-1930 la tonne mère d'Apollon de
Diane et maîtresse de Jupiter peut en
tout cas maintenant à nouveau ouvrir
depuis la terrasse la grande perspective
dans le parc du château avec une fierté
toute retrouvée
comme tous les mercredis la chronique
cinéphile on commence tout d'abord avec
le coup de coeur d'un professionnel du
7e art ce soir Cyril Haddad du cinéma
Espace Philippe Noiret des
Clayes-sous-Bois
cette semaine notre coup de cœur est le
film croate bonté divine le jeu ne
prêtre Fabian arrive dans une petite île
au croate pour reprendre les rênes de la
paroisse préoccupé par le taux de
natalité médiocre il met en oeuvre un
plan pour inverser la tendance en
complicité avec le vendeur du kiosque
local pétard très religieux il se met à
percer tous les préservatifs vendus par
ce dernier à ce plan s'associe le
pharmacien marine qui remplace les
pilules contraceptives par des vitamines
très vite mariage et naissance se
multiplient un phénomène qui amène vite
sur l'île une foule de visiteurs
étrangers qui n'arrive pas à concevoir
tournez dans un village superbe au bord
de l'eau cette farce étonne autant
qu'elle détonne
cette comédie croate s'amuse des excès
de la religion et du nationalisme
exacerbé en faisant de quelques capotes
trouvées le sujet d'un film truculent le
film abat joliment les tabous en
choisissant le parti du burlesque
le film est soutenu par Charlie Hebdo et
Charb avait même réalisé le petit dessin
figurant sur la fiche
bonté divine est à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace Philippe Moret
on continue avec du cinéma toute cette
semaine à Nicolas kiridovitz de radio
sensation et sur la Croisette à Cannes
poursuivre les yinois présent lors de ce
festival et ce soir rencontre avec un
jeune réalisateur Nicolas campsofa il
vient présenter son second court-métrage
2000 c'est le nombre de films inscrits
au Short Film Corner un espace
uniquement dédié au court-métrage en
plein cœur du Palais des Festivals ici
le court-métrage est un passage quasi
obligé pour les réalisateurs c'est une
manière de faire ses preuves c'est
également l'occasion de se faire
connaître auprès des professionnels avec
son film Jeanne livinois Nicolas kamso a
été sélectionné pour le Short Film
Corner le jeune homme de 22 ans réalise
ainsi son rêve et Nicolas aurait
peut-être pu faire carrière dans le
football signe blessure à la jambe à
l'âge de 13 ans ne l'avait pas obligé à
abandonner les terrains et à se tourner
vers la vidéo le montage puis la
réalisation Nicolas a désormais trouvé
sa voie on commence à faire des vidéos
des vidéos je m'étais dit pendant deux
ans ça y est c'est ça que ce que je vais
faire je vais plus faire du montage
c'est faire de la réalisation donc c'est
devenu une passion presque
presque addictive vraiment c'est
obsessionnel c'est j'ai besoin de faire
des films tous les ans j'ai besoin de
créer quoi donc c'est venu comme ça et
je suis très très content de pouvoir
faire du cinéma après on vit pas
forcément que sa passion mais
en tout cas faut essayer de casser les
murs quoi et pour casser les murs il met
toutes les chances de son côté Nicolas
qui n'a pas fait d'étude de cinéma est
un autodidacte et veut se faire
connaître l'an passé il était déjà venu
présenté à Cannes un film sur le
football amateur mais après au bout d'un
moment les gars il faut se poser les
questions qu'est-ce que je veux devenir
donc qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de devenir
dans le football réussir ça veut dire
quoi aller au plus haut des niveaux
international aujourd'hui Nicolas
revient un Short Film Corner l'espace
dédié au court-métrage avec un autre
film visionnable par l'ensemble des
festivaliers le plus grand intérêt c'est
le pouvoir avant tout projeter mes films
parce qu'on peut avoir des salles de
projection donc présenter des films à
des producteurs et puis aussi d'avoir
une petite carte de visite aussi parce
qu'il faut pas se mentir je shopping
corner est un bon marché pour
on va dire des marchés d'autres
festivals internationaux et aussi bien
nationaux ou régionaux dans notre pays
pour moi c'est le premier intérêt d'être
sur le Film Corner et le second c'est de
pouvoir faire des rencontres en tout cas
dans notre milieu des acteurs
des producteurs des distributeurs
Nicolas et donc descendu sous le soleil
de la Croisette pour défendre son
deuxième court-métrage Jeanne l'histoire
de Gaëlle un ancien cambrioleur qui
s'évade de prison pour aller se
recueillir sur la tombe de sa mère et à
travers sa cavale il entreprend une
quête du pardon envers ses proches et
lui-même
jamais tout ta gueule
je crois que c'est toi
simé il est venu assez rapidement parce
que on va dire que je voulais rendre
hommage à ma mère parce que bon même si
elle est pas morte et que c'est le film
est assez romancé on va dire que ça
j'avais été souvent eu des rapports très
très conflictuels avec ma mère ce qui a
fait que je voulais un petit peu me
pardonner on va dire envers ma mère
parce que j'ai pas été un enfant très
très facile et donc du coup ben j'ai
fait ce film là pour elle et puis
essayer de aussi sur le plan artistique
de passer un cap et d'évoluer parce
qu'il fallait je me suis décidé de
produire ce film là tout seul et toutes
ces économies ils sont passées tourner
ce film de 15 minutes lui a coûté plus
de 3500 euros pour passer à l'étape
suivante Nicolas doit maintenant boucler
un budget plus conséquent afin de
réaliser son premier long-métrage
baptisé provisoirement fratern c'est un
film qui est qui devrait parler de la
banlieue alors j'aime beaucoup faire des
sociaux on va dire essayer de faire
montrer
les messages faire passer des messages
de notre société qui c'est ce sont des
thèmes qui me parlent vraiment et c'est
pour ça que je vais faire un film sur la
banlieue en tout cas j'espère l'année
prochaine quoi à seulement 22 ans le
jeune homme qui vit à Mantes-la-Jolie et
déterminé à faire de sa passion son
métier Nicolas kamsofa pour devise une
citation du Petit Prince d'Antoine de
Saint-Exupéry fait de ta vie un rêve et
d'un rêve une réalité
et l'ensemble des chroniques canauxes de
Nicolas kerylovitz sont également à
retrouver sur le site internet de
téléfil 78 radio sensation c'est sûr
98.4 cette émission maintenant terminée
merci de l'avoir suivi rendez-vous
mercredi prochain nous parlerons du
festival banlieusard bonne semaine